[Music]
news that shocked many fans of the Jerry
Springer Show after 27 years on air are
its chair tossing onstage cat fighting
days numbered only I spoke to Jerry
today
there is a lot of speculation about the
show can you set the record straight
about what is going on we've stopped
production of the show we've already
shot some shows for next season
technically the shoals not canceled no I
don't know what that means we're not in
production so but the show is still
airing so that's I guess why they don't
use use that term the 74 year old says
they shot dozens of new episodes that
will air on the CW in the fall
production just wrapped two weeks ago
our show beyond in most cities twice a
day it'll be mostly from these four
thousand shows we've done so every once
in a while you'll be seeing shows where
I look a lot younger
right now there's no plan to shoot any
more new episodes but Jerry says that
could change the show's I understand
he'll be on for at least another two
three years and that still continues to
rate good then they'll do some more
whenever you make changes it said as for
Jerry well he plans to keep busy other
people have come and talked about
possible television projects but I don't
know that I can maintain this schedule
that I was which you know has been
insane for these years you take a break
Jerry you deserve it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]